in der Kürze liegt die Würze und in
Maggis Brühwürfeln auch der kleine
Brocken hier sorgt für 10 Liter Suppe
der Riesen Geschmack in dem winzigen
Würfel kommt unter anderem durch
Glutamat das völlig zu Unrecht
verteufelt wird Sebastian deckt auf
warum Glutamat sogar hilfreich sein kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
könnte Brühe zum würzen und verfeinern
[Musik]
und schon haben richtig würziger Typ
gartengemüsebouillon ich will meine
Gartenbank gesehen wo die das Gemüse
Abbauen der Brühwürfel ist die
geschmacksbombe im Sortiment seit mehr
als 120 Jahren verspricht Maggi
fantastisches Aroma im Handumdrehen
haben Sie sich schon mal gefragt wie man
so viel Geschmack in so einen kleinen
Würfel bekommt das zeige ich Ihnen jetzt
ein kleiner Würfel reicht für einen
halben Liter Suppe was steckt da drin
Sebastian lege geht der Sache auf den
Grund
erste Zutat
und dann Mono Natrium Glutamat
der Brühwürfel von Maggi besteht vor
allem aus Salz
mononatrium glutamat ist ein
Geschmacksverstärker einige Kräuter und
Gewürze sind auch enthalten
das war schon 1886 so damals erfindet
ein gewisser Julius Maggi die berühmte
flüssigwürze angeblich einzigartig
Ausgangsprodukt sind anfangs Sojabohnen
und Weizen die werden damals durch Lauge
chemisch so verändert dass Glutamat
entsteht Maggi hat einen
Geschmacksverstärker entdeckt die Basis
für einen Weltkonzern
1900 kommt Julius Magi dann auf die Idee
den herzhaft würzigen Geschmack trocken
gepresst zu verkaufen der Brühwürfel
wird zum Weltall heute wird das Glutamat
für Maggi Produkte von speziellen
Bakterien produziert unter idealen
Bedingungen vermehren sie sich und
produzieren reines Glutamat Sebastian
lege setzt die optimierte Nährlösung an
ich sag mal so Musik läuft in der Disco
brennt schon Licht aber irgendeiner muss
auf der Tanzfläche eine Runde dancen
ansonsten haben wir keine Stimmung und
das ist das Bakterium
[Musik]
das ist ein Bakterium was dafür sorgt
dass alles fermentiert wir machen so ein
bisschen muschelig warm ne so richtig
schöne 40 Grad und da können die sich
vermehren und vermehren und vermehren
[Musik]
stehen lassen
aber er braucht man da gar nicht
mitmachen nach 48 Stunden haben die
Bakterien die Nährlösung aus malzsirup
und Wasser umgewandelt
[Gelächter]
Disco ist geschlossen die Bakterien
haben genug getan jetzt steckt in dieser
Masse schon richtig viel Glutamat aber
hier sind noch so viele andere Sachen
drinne die wollen wir gar nicht haben
Sebastian lege setzt der braunen Brühe
Kaliumcarbonat zu in der Industrie ein
beliebtes Lehrmittel es entfernt
störende Trübstoffe aus Flüssigkeiten
die setzen sich dann unten im Topf ab
[Musik]
oh ja hier sieht man schon ne da setzt
sich schon so eine gewisse Schlacke
unten ab man merkt wie das Bild ja
perfekt jetzt muss der Produktentwickler
die gebundenen Stoffe nur noch aus
seinem Glutamat Brei herausfiltern
meine Damen und Herren nennen sie mich
lege giver
mit einem Filter Marke Eigenbau will der
Produktentwickler den Reinheitsgrad
erhöhen es soll eine klare Flüssigkeit
werden weil Glutamat will man ja überall
einsetzen können und es soll ja nicht
färben
reines glutamat ist schneeweiß dafür
wird es in der Industrie mehrfach
gefiltert und gereinigt
das ist filtrationsstufe Nummer eins
zwar nicht so perfekt wie das Original
aber es reicht den Filtrat entzieht
Sebastian lege jetzt das Wasser dafür
setzt er einen Kochtopf ein der mit
Unterdruck arbeitet
läuft
läuft im Unterdruck kochen das spart
Zeit und Energie wenig Inhaltsstoffe
gehen verloren nur das Wasser verdampft
und und
[Gelächter]
wow das nenne ich mal Konzentration der
größte Teil an Wasser ist jetzt raus
aber noch nicht alles es soll ja
riesenfähig sein weil nur trockene
Produkte lassen sich weltweit wunderbar
verschiffen und sind super händelbar
weil sie gammeln nicht und und und und
aus Sirup ein Pulver machen Sebastian
liege schafft das mit einem einfachen
Dörrautomaten
und
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der kleine Brocken hier sorgt für 10
Liter Suppe
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das hat richtig Bums das macht einmal
richtig Tango auf der Zunge Sebastian
lege hat Maggis berühmten
Geschmacksverstärker selber hergestellt
für drei Kilo Brühwürfel braucht er fast
ein Kilo Glutamat
zweite Zutat
[Musik]
und noch mehr Salz
ach ist das schön
ich sag mal ich mache jetzt hier
drei Kilo rührwürfel das ist eine
Badewanne voll flüssiger Brühe
so rund eineinhalb Kilo Salz kommen
gemüsearoma
ein Schuss sellerieöl etwas
Karamellzucker für die Farbe und für
lange Haltbarkeit eine künstliche
hergestellte Säure
Zitronensäure damit das Teil auch nicht
gammelt das schöne ist er liegt ja
ungekühlt im Regal das heißt unendlich
haltbar
und jetzt braucht die Brühe auch noch so
ihre Geschmeidigkeit das soll ja
aussehen wie richtige Brühe wo die Augen
nach oben aufsteigen das Fett
kommt aber hier von der Palme und nicht
vom Huhn
kein Fett bleibt bei Raumtemperatur Fest
eine Bohrmaschine treibt die selbst
gebaute maggi-mischmaschine an
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass sich das Palmfett gut
verteilt es hält beim Pressen alle
Pulver Zutaten zusammen
[Musik]
überall muss der gleiche Anteil am Masse
drin sein Presse geht runter
es reicht doch nicht zum Verpressen
warte ich nehme Gewicht
ja hallo so
die würfelpresse funktioniert unter
hohem Druck am besten okay
das Ergebnis sind aroma-würfel nach
Pflegeart ich würde mal sagen sehr gut
verpresst
mit heißem Wasser wird aus dem Würfel im
Handumdrehen eine herzhafte Brühe
[Musik]
so ein kleiner Würfel macht einen halben
Liter Brühe und das ganze nur wegen der
zauberzutat Glutamat
[Musik]
für die schmeckt aber komisch
Glutamat steckt den praktisch allen
Produkten von Maggi oder Knorr dabei ist
der Geschmacksverstärker in letzter Zeit
in Verruf geraten das heißt oft Glutamat
sei gesundheitsschädlich was ist dran
[Musik]
Besserwisser Florian Reza klärt auf
heute im Angebot
hefeextrakte und Glutamat von Maggi und
Knorr
Glutamat finden ja viele bäh und krank
machen soll es auch Parkinson Alzheimer
Krebs der hört man wirklich üble Sachen
die Wahrheit ist unser Körper besteht
aus dem Zeug rund 2 Kilo stecken in
jedem von uns
glutamat ist eine von 20 Aminosäuren die
in allen Lebensmitteln stecken auch in
uns Menschen in Bienen und Blumen Weizen
Soja Rindern Tomaten Pilzen alles
enthält Glutamat
[Musik]
etwa 20 Gramm nehmen wir mit unserer
Nahrung täglich auf 50 Gramm stellt
unser Körper jeden Tag selbst her als
Baumaterial für Eiweiße und als
Botenstoffe im Gehirn
[Musik]
trotzdem glauben viele dass Glutamat
krank macht richtig ist glutamatisch
steht tatsächlich im Verdacht
Krankheiten wie Alzheimer Krebs oder
Parkinson zu verursachen aber es geht
hier nicht um das Glutamat dass wir mit
der Nahrung aufnehmen sondern um das vom
Körper selbst hergestellt das Glutamat
aus der Nahrung kann die bluthirn
Schranke nicht passieren die unser
Gehirn verschiedlichen Stoffen schützt
deshalb kann das das Gehirn noch nicht
schädigen
[Musik]
es ist also so so wissenschaftler haben
herausgefunden dass zu viel
körpereigenes Glutamat in unserem Hirn
Schaden anrichten kann das hat Glutamat
im Essen in Verruf gebracht
dabei sind Maggi Knorr und all die
anderen nicht für Alzheimer oder
Parkinson verantwortlich denn ihr
Glutamat wirkt auf der Zunge als
Geschmacksverstärker und wird zum
größten Teil von unseren Darmbakterien
verbraucht
das wahre Problem ist die Brühwürfel von
Maggi und Knorr machen Essen
geschmackvoll und sehr salzig etwa zur
Hälfte bestehen die Produkte aus reinem
Salz das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem
wenn man
prozessierte Lebensmittel hat da gehört
der Magie Würfel dazu dass die
tendenziell zu viel Salz enthalten und
von dem wissen wir das ist schädlich ist
für uns weil es zu hohen Blutdruck macht
Schlaganfälle macht Herzinfarkt
in den Industrienationen haben sich die
Gesundheitssysteme laut WHO auf die
salzreiche Ernährung eingestellt
die orange markierten Staaten sind
dagegen mit dem Salz Problem überfordert
Beispiel Kenia dort werden westliche
Industrieprodukte wie der Brühwürfel
immer beliebter Magie wirkt den Kenia
offensiv für seine Brühwürfel mit
hühnchengeschmack
[Musik]
Magie verspricht den Party Geschmack im
Würfel der Slogan Magie macht jede Frau
zum Star
in Nairobi der Hauptstadt Kenias geht es
wirtschaftlich bergauf die Mittelschicht
wächst für die Marken der westlichen
Industrienationen ein interessanter
Markt
eines der populärsten Produkte überhaupt
ist seit einigen Jahren der Brühwürfel
auf dem Markt oder in kleinen
nachbarschaftsläden überall werden sie
in kleinsten Portionen angeboten sie
gelten als praktisch modern und schick i
like ich mag den Geschmack den
Brühwürfel meinem Essen geben und dass
sie so handlich sind
ich mag den Geschmack und das so viele
Gewürze in einem Würfel drin sind damit
kann man gut kochen ich benutze
[Musik]
50 Millionen Brühwürfel verkauft Maggi
in Afrika pro Tag dabei sind die im
Gegensatz zu Deutschland alles andere
als billig
Einkommens bereinigt kostet so ein
maggi-würfel über 20 Cent in Deutschland
sind es um die 18 die Würfel verkaufen
sich trotzdem bestens in diesem Bistro
in Kenia gibt es typisch afrikanisches
street food Chef am Bluse setzt auf
Brühwürfel für ihn ist es das
Erfolgsrezept
ich verwende die Brühwürfel in vielen
meiner Gerichte ich verwende sie in
Currys oder wenn ich Rindfleisch
zubereitet zum Beispiel T-Bone dann
verwende ich die Würfel in der Marinade
oder auch bei Chicken Wings eigentlich
immer wenn es schmecken soll
mit dem Brühwürfel importiert Kenia die
Gesundheitsprobleme der
Industrienationen
inzwischen liegt der Salzkonsum vieler
afrikanischer Länder mehr als doppelt so
hoch wie von der WHO empfohlen
ein Produkt wieder Brühwürfel aus 50%
Salz ist Teil des Problems
Maggi tut sich schwer den Salzgehalt
seiner Würfel zu reduzieren in Kenia und
auf der ganzen Welt dabei liegt laut
Weltgesundheitsorganisation die Lösung
auf der Hand Firmen sollten mehr
Glutamat und weniger Salz verwenden und
wenn Sie das Benutzen zum Würzen ist es
besser als wenn sie den Brühwürfel
benutzen und deshalb überlegen sich
Regierungen also ganz konkret zum
Beispiel in England oder in Japan die
man durch
vermehrten Einsatz von Glutamat den
Kochsalzkonsum in der Bevölkerung
insgesamt reduzieren können
so ließe sich der Magie Geschmack ohne
gesundheitliche Nebenwirkungen erhalten
glutamat ist nicht das Problem sondern
überraschenderweise die Lösung
[Musik]